hello everyone
a couple of weeks earlier i had made a
video on uh viva preparation and that
seemed to have helped a few guys so i
thought
on a similar line i'll make another
video
for
the project presentations especially the
bachelors and the master's levels
presentations
because in a few days from now here at
iit kharagpur we are going to have
our
presentation rounds
now uh although
the things that i'm going to discuss is
based on my experiences as a student and
as a faculty over the past few years
here at iit kharagpur specifically the
mechanical engineering department i
think
the things are general enough for it to
be helpful
for this video to be helpful to students
in general from other institutes also so
without further ado let's get into the
discussion
so even before one goes into the
presentation the work starts much before
that so
the first thing which students
the the question which which comes to
the student's mind is regarding the
length of the presentation now i think
that
if you are putting something in your
presentation you should be investing a
reasonable amount of time in explaining
that
that slide
so uh for a 10 or 15 minute presentation
i think you need about at least a minute
not less than a minute to explain a
slide
that means that you should not be
putting more than 10 or 15 slides in
your presentation
okay so the first thing to remember is
that your presentation is not equal okay
i repeat it is absolutely not equal to
your report or your thesis
okay so your presentation is basically
just a showcasing uh or a highlighting
of the main things that you have done in
your work
all right so uh
in a technical presentation usually have
we have various sections like the
introduction the
uh the problem statement the
mathematical modeling the simulation
work uh the results and discussions and
if you're doing some kind of experiment
experimental work you have to include
that uh instead of the mathematical
modeling or if you're doing some kind of
mathematical modeling work plus
experiments you have to explain both of
them anyway so for the introduction what
you have to say is the you know what you
have to give
is the
background as well as the motivation for
your work meaning why you are doing what
you are doing if you are not clear about
this point discuss with your supervisor
and write accordingly in your
presentation
next your problem statement should be
absolutely clear to written i have seen
this not being presented
at all
or not very clearly by the students so
this is a very rookie mistake you should
not do this okay your problem statement
should be absolutely clearly written
maybe with the help of a schematic
that's very good and if possible discuss
with your supervisor and see if you can
actually state your problem statement in
the form of a question for example what
is the influence of this on that
okay or how or how does that influence
this something like on that on that line
next for the
literature survey
what students usually do is they list
reference after reference or maybe they
just
wait till the end and they just list out
the references at one go i don't think
that's a very good idea okay what i
personally do is that when i am putting
my background and my motivation for the
work as well as the problem statement i
try to put the relevant references the
primary references the important ones as
footnotes in those very slides
okay so it is immediate it is absolutely
relevant and it's short
okay
next regarding the mathematical modeling
well uh again the students are a little
bit confused here
because
they have sometimes they they have done
page after page of mathematical
derivations uh and sometimes they tend
to put everything together in the in the
presentation again this should not be
done
okay rather
what you can do is you can put the main
governing equations together with the
boundary conditions and initial
conditions
and
even more importantly
you should be discussing the important
length scales and time scales
in that mathematical modeling part
highlight what are the important
non-dimensional parameters if any
okay
now up to this point when you are
describing your work you should
somewhere within these slides within
this first five or six slides you should
try to ensure that
somewhere you highlight very very
clearly very emphatically what is the
novelty in your work maybe right in the
problem statement itself or somewhere
within the mathematical modeling part or
somewhere else okay you should be
absolutely clear about what is the
novelty in your work
at the bachelor's level
it may be a little bit difficult because
sometimes the works are not such great
in scope that there is necessarily a new
thing but there must be something
different compared to the previously
published works which you are doing
so try to highlight that so this is the
one of the worst mistakes that the
students make of not highlighting it in
the front of here
in front of their examining professor
next up
comes the simulation work so if you have
done some kind of simulation the natural
tendency of the student is to go into
great details of describing that
simulation work meaning
what kind of activities they have done
or what are the steps they have taken in
the
software whether it is a free or open
source software or some kind of
proprietary software they spend a great
deal of time explaining what exactly
they have done in that software
okay please do not do this
okay the examining professor is not
really interested in those things
i mean there does exist exceptions
but mostly this is the case
so instead what you should be doing is
that
that particular software
is using some kind of mathematical
backend
okay so maybe it is using finite element
methods or finite volume methods you
explain that okay explain that means you
explain that your work has these these
non-linear equations or these these
coupled equations and these cannot be
solved by hand or analytically which is
why you have to take recourse to such
and such and software and that software
is solving these equations
uh using uh this particular method like
finite volume method or finite element
method
okay that's it
and maybe if it is doing some kind of
time stepping then you discuss a little
bit regarding that's the time stepping
method which the software uh is doing
and please note that uh
you actually have to investigate a
little bit what the software is doing so
a little bit of preparation on that
regard is also absolutely necessary okay
so you must give the impression in front
of the examining professor that you have
not blindly run the software okay you
have kind of understood what is going on
at the back end
next regarding regarding the results and
discussions uh
going back to the initial point that i
had made that your presentation is not
equal to your thesis or report uh you
should not be giving all your results in
your presentation suppose your in your
your report you have 12 figures uh
please do not put all of them in your
presentation okay maybe put a few okay
three four or mad max five
or something on that order
around that so now
the idea here is that if you are
if you're putting a figure you should be
absolutely clearly explaining that
so
you put a panel in a particular slide
and then
as if you are explaining to a blind
person you say that we have this on the
x axis we have that on the y axis and
then we can see the variation of this y
versus the x as if as it is increasing
like this maybe it is decreasing like
that so this kind of a thing as if you
were explaining to a blind person you
should be saying that okay
if there is some physical justification
to that kind of an of a degree of an
increasing decreasing trend try to
explain that that actually shows that
you have not just repeatedly run the
software to obtain some kind of plots
rather you have actually understood what
the results are what the physical
significance of the results are that is
of crucial importance in front of the
examining professor that is what he or
she wants to see actually
next
uh you have to go to your
conclusions
if possible it would be very nice that
you highlight how your the results that
you have found out that ties in to the
novelty of the work which you had
initially stated
okay so earlier i had mentioned that you
should be explaining what is something
what is the kernel of a new idea that is
present in your work and if somehow your
results can be tied in to that uh that
new thing then it would be very really
nice so that initial maybe that initial
question had the novelty itself that
what is the influence of that maybe
nobody had asked that earlier so try to
explain at in the conclusions instead of
giving
10 bullet points in the in the
conclusion slide just maybe give two or
three bullet points but those let those
two or three bullet points be very very
impactful in the sense that you
absolutely clearly show that you have
answered
that initial question
okay so now it is the time for the
uh that insider
secret uh so it's it it's like this
you see uh
everyone has an ego
okay professors have an ego also
now most of the ego of a professor is
tied into his personal intelligence so
we will always think that
we are very smart okay however true that
may or may not be will always think like
that so when a student is presenting in
front of us and we are examining it and
we somehow we don't get it very rarely
we will admit that we are not getting it
because of some shortcoming in our own
understanding okay very very rarely will
admit it rather our
our our reaction will be that we are not
getting it because the student has not
been explained has not been able to
explain to it properly to us so it is
your duty as as as a student presenting
your work to explain your work in as
clear a manner as possible actually this
goes for any kind of presentation the
most successful kind of presentation is
the one where you have managed to leave
your audience
feeling intelligent about himself or
herself because that leaves a feeling of
great satisfaction in his or her mind so
on that note i will end this video all
the very best on your preparation for
your presentation and all the very best
on your actual presentation thank you